[Music]
look you had one speech Berkeley to show
the world but your Jewish ass ain't no
Nazi do you pay the $10,000 security
deposit or you just stay home with that
[ __ ] ass tumbler well listen the bottom
line is that was that was a rumor
factually I'm not gonna let students any
fascists keep me off campus that was
simply not going to happen as it relates
to the the tumbler of course it's a it's
a quality item it's double wall
insulated and we're actually selling it
out for a Barry that seemed very least a
bit inappropriate to play well I am
finishing out
coverage for all no discrimination based
on pre-existing conditions at long last
mr. president here is your Emmy famous
rapper who once bragged about Cod made
me bulletproof was shot and killed
yesterday turns out that actually God
sided with his notorious foe MC
armor-piercing bullets not donut do not
go further without consent but Your
Honor I couldn't no said all the rapists
who suck at pictionary maybe it's the
fact that for Miami you wore a t-shirt
of the guy who raped their fan bases
moms
[Music]
it's amazing how smart you have to be to
create something that stupid yes that's
not gonna get trending
[Music]
[Music]
that's the unenthusiastic Morocco's ah
favourite how to recognize it
it's a favorite on hot mexican days hey
before we get to our we have three we
have three before guests today shortly
sort of yeah question of the day do you
believe that the roles on the left and
right have swapped on free speech since
the 60s we'll be talking about that
because free speech a week is coming up
where's the left and never really cared
about free speech I think I mean it was
more of a prodrug
anti-war movement than it was so much
about speech in the 60s and second
question on a scale of one to Mel Brooks
how Jewish is Ben Shapiro not gay Jared
follow him on Twitter at not gay Jared
he's not gay me at us cried with York on
occasional thoughts your photoshop's
I fulfill my legal obligations during
conclusions are we good we're gonna good
enough that'll do Gerald at G Morgan jr.
is here what's the line of the day
mister sommelier the one of the day is
Dow we've talked about this yesterday
notorious this man recommended notorious
hey I got a new recommendation for you
you know notorious to its out you should
say just one static shot of a grape it's
a big apology to the 31 if you've never
seen it it's terrible yeah yeah that was
a straight outta compton fan he read two
hours of my life that will never get
back we spent half just showing it
yesterday but I'm still I'm still sore
about 30 seconds in my life I'll never
get back we're even we'll be talking
about before a free speech we kinda get
in the history of it why Vox hates free
speech along with Jimmy Kimmel we are
going to have clean Howard on the show
yeah that's always fun an incredible
ride that we actually get him on the
show and he gets his stuff working we're
gonna have an McIlhenny and flume a clue
they have their Ferguson play going into
the heart of Manhattan and then we have
senator Rick Santorum talking about the
new the new Cassidy up all weed up as
just made-up words and if you say that's
not a word that's racist so good line up
before we get to that we have to address
the angry elf in the room a video that
went viral of MSNBC's O'Donnell is on it
do we have a clip of his we just have
the first clip well today President
Trump visited Texas but he forgot to
bring any empathy with him but he did
bring a hat a hat that is for sale
58 what's going on why am i losing this
why don't I have sound all right its
back
someone's pressing buttons and turning
my sound of who was who's asking for a
Labor Day run down in my ear someone in
that control room is out of control so
it's it's you know I my heart goes out
to the guy I see it you can see the rage
bills in here and we've all been there
you know what you want to sympathize
well I will say this when I was at Fox
News I remember I used to be in that
when you were in the newsroom they
didn't have cubicles and they must have
people like it was a call center
answering phones on their keyboards and
they were just obnoxious yeah where it's
coming from the the voice-acting world
people are you know it's on air quiet on
radio right so of course listen the guy
the guy still dick but it changes the
context a little bit we've actually
acquired exclusive audio from his
earpiece and there's a little more
empathy well today President Trump
visited Texas but he forgot to bring any
empathy with him but he did bring a hat
a hat for sale what's going on why am I
losing all right it's back
someone's pressing buttons returning my
sound bang who was who's asking for a
Labor Day rundown in my ear someone in
that control room is out of control so
the president went to Texas Yves Paris
who had been missing since Sunday now
you have insanity in my earpiece
somebody talking on our lines
President Trump did not mention sergeant
Paris I don't interview - Mike today
complaining about misogyny and Devils
Sochi this is a quote she had the clip
we won't subject you to the actual video
Thank You c'n she said we've end the
double standard adding that too often
women are seen as angry when they
advocate for causes they believe in
rather than as passionate well no it's
just you what really bothers me and I
know my wife but people like Hillary
Clinton
stop conflating all women with you
Aretha Franklin no one's upset about her
passionate singing talking about RESP
ECT no one cares oh no Rose we have laud
shouldn't everyone applaud her pet Sarah
McLachlan she's passionate about dogs
she doesn't complain that you didn't
adopt a dog because she's a woman she
just gets it done every time I turn that
TV she's saying you know I said hey
listen I wish it were I wish it didn't
play during my children's cartoon but I
appreciate your passion Sarah McLachlan
you're the woman Hillary who legally had
people killed and lost the most winnable
presidency ever okay so maybe it's not
it's just you yeah you're gonna say
she's a Michael Jackson of politics like
maybe she served a purpose I want
initiative she demands but she's just a
leech on society that will not just go
away she has she had her moment and she
missed it it she just doesn't know how
to deal with it you pretty Camus senator
when she got an apartment just outside
the borderline for two weeks you know
she's like oh the first black president
of course the only thing that could
trump the first
when president first black president and
then Donald Trump and she's like I got
it I got it this is it this is it what
is my diamond I know this I think this
is like normal people would go into a
home at this point just be crazy in a
padded cell but she gets to write books
yeah well I mean Bernie I think it's
like a parking garage sorry like debt is
she in this she has to keep doing this
service I don't know she gets all the
money she's the only one she Owen brave
enough to go in cuz she she knows she's
not getting sexually assaulted everyone
else in season Bernie Sanders is crazy
to me he's so crazy that I feel as
though he would he would have like he
would be just an expert in escaping
straitjackets oh I feel like you'd be
surprised have a lot of experience I'd
like to spend some time in these alright
why fortunes most powerful women's list
matters more than ever was the headline
from fortune so that's good why our
stuff matters more than all of our we
matter so included in the test was a
list the top fifty how they do it in
their most powerful women in the world
and all their accomplishments not
included on the list of accomplishments
pull ups
nothing more
so Netflix was forced this was something
to pull an episode of their children's
show Maya the beat was that an American
show just a Canadian show and now I know
it's on Netflix yeah it was my nephew's
watched it for a little while okay well
no when I was like in the early 90s okay
so Maya the be when a mother spotted a
very lewd image if you didn't catch it
there the first time I can see that
right there now they're trying to argue
was this okay
yeah listen and all this proves is that
artists it doesn't matter how good
they're they just love drawing dicks
yeah okay period it kills all this time
because all of it is he great all the
greatest of all times the classics
exciting yeah of the VHS of the original
Little Mermaid where it's just like a
gold-plated apparatus and that priests
that horny horny priest
that's true mermaids yeah yeah the bulbs
there oh that's right I feel like these
artists get so bored with like doing
some of these children's things like
you're missing it you're missing from
the kid in his in his high school
yearbook all the way to the greatest art
just artists love drawing darkness
that's what yeah
doesn't matter how skilled they are
right so you can look throughout history
it's nice to be true no no no okay no
you're wrong you're wrong look this
Sistine Chapel right there okay listen
that's not necessary could've easily put
a fig leaf there good that's true yeah
and that's small shows too
yeah it is striking so everyone knows
like there are those that you know but
there's some that you a lot of people
don't know for like the Mona Lisa
everyone knows what that looks like but
if you zoom in you look a little closer
look dick right there people don't see
it's just you have to have it it's like
that it's like the magic eye you have to
look and kind of I spy kind of like they
don't let you close enough to the closer
then you'll need to defocus to kind of
do the Rainman glaze yeah that's how you
see magic eyes see the Mona Lisa and
then something like Picasso we know
because he did all kinds of weird things
but lobule don't know they don't say if
you look at Picasso you look at his
signature even look you zoom in people
it's a dick and there is nothing to be
ashamed of the beauty of them we've
celebrated the female form so Maya the
bee should be able to celebrate through
the male form you get your hats your
[ __ ] hats the kids would have never
seen them we hit Dixon Picasso I'm
pretty sure some kid would know you had
to zoom in to really see it i pads now
they're not watching that pasti porque
stop Darrell all right this is a Fight
Club where they're putting like
someone's gonna be like yours is a
counterfeit that's right but Amazon if
they're reviewing their website after
algorithm suggests bomb-making
ingredients so this is thank God they
just bought whole foods this makes me
feel good about society the ingredients
which are legal to purchase were
included in a frequently bought together
sectional listings that included
materials like Paul bearings ignition
systems and in detonators yes there's
the classics just a suggestion from
Amazon
the rhythm gets you and yeah yeah how'd
you learn to pressure cookers for good
fun
yes yeah and then just put it in the
back of a car there was I think Nick
cappella toast but I said pressure
Carter from there you can stop pressure
cook in the back of a car and he called
the cops and he was like listen mister
pressure cooker first off he was
profiling was there duct tape around
there's a bunch of weird standby right I
will have him on to talk about it soon
but of course does this open up an
entire investigation to Amazon if you
haven't been following this but this
isn't actually the only case of this
malicious use of the platform yeah the
algorithm there a neural net processor
there a learning computer so the
algorithms I love but they've also
suggested for example customers who
bought bedsheets it suggested you might
also purchase SPF 300 best of limp
Biskit and tiki torches and a big
promise was enabling location services
if you were in Charlotte guide turn that
part of the phone off yeah because now I
can warn you while you're while you're
driving it's like are you in a Dodge
Challenger do you want to damage Siri
frequently virgins again also if you're
if you were buying teddy bears that
suggested lollipops and window tint
which I didn't even know is a purchase
you can make to purchase window tint an
independent goes by the way state to
state law depends where you're like so
and if you were purchasing the Ryan
Gosling criterion directors box set it
suggested dark chocolate and
industrial-strength my doll really like
it's not dangerous it's just really sad
it's very intent but it's also sad it's
also relieving it is light all the
robots are trying to help us they're not
here to think people know there's so
many sponsor there's do you think that
we fit that in right we fit that in
pretty well thank you thank you my tall
feather too right in there
[Laughter]
none of us can judge Clint Howard
varying bizarre okay so free speech week
is gonna kick off at some point is but
we're kind of exhausted with it
obviously because Ben was already there
and now there's going to be Milo and
Coulter Vox wrote an article on this and
I think it is picture perfect again
question the day is do you think that
the right and left swapped roles on free
speech
I don't think so we've talked about that
with Reuben or Sargon like you know I'm
a classical liberal I don't think I
understood your going back all the way
to you know Jefferson fine but I think
people think you know when they think
JFK is classical liberal now so Fox
wrote this article and it is just it's
picture picture-perfect proof ok so
right away what should throw throw throw
you for a loop is free speeches and
quotes that's kind of a red flag not
just free speech week he scroll through
it says when conservatives talk about
free speech what and there's no capitals
on free and free speech there's no salad
you're saying okay it's a it's that
we're using this as a noun no they just
free speech they're hedging their bets
so right away in Vox they write one of
the reasons people are so opposed to
these free speech events is because
these conservative activists often use
the mantle of free speech to say some
really bigoted offensive things okay so
they do their obligatory First Amendment
but really and then they go right right
there right into the condemn in the
speech and they say again and again
people told me how much they resented
not being able to speak their minds
though none of them wanted to articulate
what exactly they were holding in well
how about they didn't want to articulate
it because you are going to say that
they're using it to say really bigoted
offensive things before they said
anything call it a hunch
then they go on to say in the same
article on Vox some liberals have argued
that this conservative defense of free
speech is really a ruse to say all sorts
of racist sexist and other bigoted
things which is really just a it's a
repeat of the first quote that I read
it's almost like a summary but they felt
the need to reiterate it now why could
conservatives possibly why could they
possibly want to avoid you this is why
this is my
aren't accurate people are afraid
because everyone what do you think about
Donald Trump oh shoot if I answer he's
gonna say I'm gonna take this is
seriously bigoted he wrote about it
twice wrote a few times in that article
put free speech in coats it's like the
only thought that I have coming across
my head is something racist or sexist
that I could say out loud it shows their
contempt for free speech anyway as far
as why would they why are they afraid of
being sound there plenty of examples
it's just in the last week you have Milo
you have been Shapiro you have an
Coulter it's it's non-stop this is
because you've preemptively tried to
silence conservatives with the
accusation of bigotry this is nothing
new now here's something the left only
obviously has liked free speech when it
benefits them yeah and we saw that when
it was code pink okay now it's true that
the left champion free speech or the
term free speech this sort of free
speech movement started in Berkeley
right against the Vietnam War in the 60s
okay now I maintain that was really just
more of an anti-war prodrug movement if
you actually go back and read the
literature sure it was called free
speech it was called the Free Speech
Movement in Berkeley mmm okay but it was
more the free love movement the feminist
movement if you look at what they were
actively fighting for it was never about
free speech as a matter of fact you can
still find plenty of examples of them
being offended and not wanting people to
say what they thought were hateful
things I mean didn't use the terminology
hate speech so this is what I want to
hear from other people think that well
it was the catalyst was Berkeley the
Free Speech Movement that's actually not
what hippies were about I also find it
ironic they have the free speech circle
in Berkeley we used to have it in South
America but they would support free
speech much no and it's almost like
people just take it at such face value
they they just there's really a problem
people saying well black lives matter is
against hate and bigotry that's what
they said on the marquee the flyer said
that's what drew anti-fascists yeah they
must hate really a fascism you know so
sex you got it look beyond just what the
title was of the movement because it's
you know they co-opted it I mean they
absolutely co-opted it the free speech
when you look up and back Danny and I
say I think if I'm not mistaken Reagan
was governor and I would say weren't
allowed to have political activism on
campus I get it I think they were right
with it but the point is that was never
the main component of the hippie
movement it wasn't like there was a huge
movement across the country on all these
different campuses Kampai
always so I think one of the things too
is I know that we're going back to
Berkeley because of the 1960s stuff but
I also I also kind of think it's because
you know you're gonna get some protests
occasionally so I'm okay with no don't
get me wrong I'm just saying as somebody
who supports free speech sometimes I
kind of wonder did they co-opted in the
60s are we kind of co-opting it a little
bit right now just to get something on
the news milos a flame thrower he always
has been a flame thrower life support is
right to do are you talking about him in
with him in Milo but yeah with Milo as
an example but Ben Shapiro wasn't no it
wasn't and nobody I mean they wouldn't
sat in I mean I guess they're going to
you when I went to UMass or when I was
you know when I was at Cal Poly I wasn't
that's just why I stopped doing colleges
it was like either either I'm going to
be able to perform or I'm not and now
we're talking about maybe going back and
trying to do colleges again me and Owen
because who cares if they prove us out
yeah yeah and I've already heard much
thing about antiphon stuff this weekend
at Berkeley I don't know if they're just
like a little little tuckered I will
spend from their other vegan diets aw
realize how deep the antifa stuff goes
we'll have some insight into that next
week but they even supported free speech
you can say okay there was this incident
Berkeley in the 60s fine any example
since then I for example in the in the
80s it was Reagan's FCC and wanted to
eliminate the Fairness Doctrine which
controlled freedom speech of the press
and I know some people say the Fairness
dog that sounds so good just like net
neutrality now if you want to be
consistent on the Freedom Train right
fairness that was run Alegent Democrats
have repeatedly tried to bring it back
again there's no consistency since then
don't bring that up as an overload only
how there's an overlay that came up so
case in point to an inbox okay they go
on to list the most severe severe
aggressions against free speech from my
lowest birthday so you can see their own
lists at Vox they write this he
repeatedly argued on Real Time with Bill
Maher that trans people are disordered
quotes
yeah but the dsm-5 the authority for
psychiatrists clearly lists gender
dysphoria as a mental disorder I just
don't I mean it's so again they would if
for example if they had Milo up their
son I guess he screamed the end were to
the top of his lungs and he said he
wanted to gas the Jews like you think
someone said hey maybe that should make
the cut over him quoting the dsm-5
someone's a typical he declared his
birthday world patriarchy day the sting
is real he's just like the slave drivers
in the cotton fields them excite other
speakers is hateful and bigoted again
you got it you got a one bright spot
Berkeley in the 60s anything since then
this is vogue so this is not just you
know Poulos several other attendees have
a history of making hateful bigoted
remarks
alright I'm prepped for it there you go
bayonet fee bandit has repeatedly backed
anti-immigrant causes by the way we need
to also have that liberal lexicon
anti-immigrant means illegal immigration
yes yes be clear so so let's
undocumented citizens repeatedly backed
anti criminal causes all right you be
the judge
Coulter has similarly taken hardline
anti criminal immigrants dances over the
years pamela geller runs an anti islam
blog i just i think that it goes on to
say she supports the Muslim ban but when
you talk about hate speech you know she
runs on tumblr say PBS is a TV channel
oh my gosh it's just it's just bags what
the fact that someone runs an anti Islam
blogging what they mean by anti Islam is
anti Sharia law right anti violations of
all the other rights that you claim to
support that kind of a and by the way
and it's a blog I mean this is in the
only reason that these people know about
Pamela Geller is because angry Muslims
tried to kill her in Texas and so they
decide to give her more guff inside with
the people the ideology of folks who've
tried to kill her hey hey I wonder like
a she could might possibly have it is
she with Islam hmm
can anyone think of it and supported
Trump's Muslim ban which by the way is
not a mother we haven't talked about a
long time you know why because it would
turned out it wasn't Muslim ban
it was a man it was he was in the news
for a week like Russia for a week so
this is what's important when the left
says we yeah free speech button you see
this from Vox by the way and Vox is is
constantly used as a source but YouTube
just cannot trend Vox enough cannot
feature them enough snopes PolitiFact
Vox they're used as these beacons or
we've talked about this before the
Southern Poverty Law Center of unbiased
truth and and Vox is effectively making
the claim here if you actually be what
they're saying that being against
radical Islamic terror in supporting
reasonable legal immigration policies is
now somehow hateful and bigoted and if
you don't want to talk to them about it
because they just said you might be
hateful and bigoted you really are
violating free speech yeah they're
missing the the free part of speech even
if all of that is true it is still free
speech for a reason it's not free speech
according to you it's free speech they
can say it just choose not to listen you
kinda start out with a bumper sticker
slogan and didn't know where to take it
has no what happened a little bit things
in the world either free speech is
absolute or it's not not just what are
you agree with George that's the whole
point with it that's what it counts shut
up about them yelling fire in a crowded
theater okay so tell this they tell us
when you make that argument is that
you're likely a [ __ ] uses Bing yes
yeah you probably still typing male I
don't word document has that bent back
paper clip paper clip Microsoft's a
little pretentious yeah but you have
that purple gorilla going across your
screen to search what does the name some
bonsais replacement how did we survive
this way if you say hey what speech does
a lie to yell fire in a crowded for some
it's just so silly it's a yes it does
actually if I'm in a theater and I say
fire because there's a funny fire scene
in that movie it's it's fine
that's not a bell fire pointing to the
alarms to try and get somebody to pull
the fire alarm and people run out of
that theater and someone gets hurt and
trampled it is the call to action that's
not about
it is so Elementary that if you actually
make that argument I think you probably
still use Ask Jeeves running back right
with Clint Howard well make sure we get
him during the break we have them
[Music]
go on proud of get you who's this uh
who's his queer fell on the piano
Tammy Roy that's own Benjamin he's a
trained musician and comedian
I don't agree Josephine
so that's new for you me judge me
you ain't got no certification I went
through the process required for the
certified Reverend on the internet to
enjoy the free time and our very minutes
are doing it for the work of our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ was feeling I
don't know do I deal in the currency of
lost souls doctrine and his license is
suspended would you shut the [ __ ] up
right
[Music]
yes no social media to plug actual house
you knew you had a first off we're glad
we're glad that you made it today I know
you were gonna be yesterday is
everything everything's good
everything's okay uh yeah it was my
phone was having a little trouble gee I
wonder how that happened yes yes why we
told well we heard that you've been torn
apart by a pack of wild dogs and wished
you a swift recovery so we're glad to
see that your you're still standing I
was in North Korea yes you and Dennis
Rodman you could you're all your
ambassadors yeah is that what a country
what a country can you imagine the pride
of like supporting the North Korean and
lacrosse team I mean I don't think yeah
I explained really don't play lacrosse
do they have dog racing I know they have
I know they I know they have dog eating
races yes dog but yeah except to eat
actually it's dog not eating festivals
dogs pretty good they're pretty soon
they're gonna have whoa what do they
call him the Supreme Leader yeah the
spring they're gonna put him on the menu
here pretty soon yeah I think so I think
he might put himself on the menu I don't
okay so there we go we can I was gonna
ask you why your weekend do you do you
have strong opinions in North Korea you
know Donald trum won before the UN said
we might completely destroy them is is
clean Howard on the decimate train
doesn't president Trump sound like he's
playing with like one of those big model
railroad sets from time to time yes but
you can pick worse places to burn right
you know I don't know all right I'll
tell you what if you go to Google Maps
and just see what North Korea
looks like from a few miles up even
though you know you can see South Korea
from a fairly close distance and then
they make you back up you know at least
the you know the consumer version they
back up and North Korea doesn't exactly
look like you know the hotbed of spa and
leisure activities no that's just Clint
Howard's house apparently this is this
that your uh your abode go yes yes yes
this is my not not to get cute about
this but my mother 14 years ago on her
deathbed was pleading with me like I've
never heard anybody say you gotta get a
jacuzzi he's gotta go to that well she
was on her deathbed that's not cute
that's horrifying
Clint well bring it down deep no she
desperately wanted her son to have a
jacuzzi see I have very much her body
and you know I have two artificial hips
she had one okay Ron's got a horrible
hip um just from years of football
practice just the wear and tear no just
being a bloodline of a couple of Hicks
the banjo from deliverance is playing
somewhere down the lineage you're saying
well actually Hicks is more like farmer
okay that's hillbilly so a little little
bit offensive yes well no Jethro would
be hillbilly yeah I tried it in my mind
I'll try to figure a great hit well my
dad he's now a sophisticated hick yeah
because he's had all these years in the
business and he's he's managed to
navigate and he's an absolute angel
mm-hm but he's a he's a hickie angel um
when he was starting out knowing what I
know of him mm-hmm I would have given
him no chance not even one percentage
point yeah I make it in the business and
he says it was luck now I think I think
there's there's something else besides
brushing off the phone yeah that was a
special effect well
special effects like this looks like the
jacuzzi from alien it looks like a
gamer's chair equivalent of a jacuzzi
what do you have going on there well I
got to be careful because does the FCC
have anything to say about what pictures
get revealed we don't care honestly just
don't send it to brett farr pass it off
as his own I think that's the captain's
chair over there okay and my mom was
right my mom was absolutely right
you really are naked in there aren't you
Clint this is this is how you prep well
we're not prepping this is the real real
deal listen curtain has been right yes
it has and I apparently have not been
raised so we're doing fine exactly
that's why we're comfortable that's why
there's a certain level of intimacy so
did this I mean is this is this I don't
know a lot about hot tubs did you did
you specifically choose this just
because it looked cool or is there
something to this because it seems as
though obviously you enjoyed enough to
do your interviews from there huh well
actually this is the first interview
guys keep it going every time you come
on well we'll allow it I put less that
you did video born in Jersey
yeah from well I'll get in the jacuzzi
with you but you said you were gonna
turn the Jets off so I don't yes well
did you yes yes you can't do a thing
with it you can't do an interview with
the Jets otherwise where are the bubbles
coming from Clint so let me ask you he
asked you this what have you even
sending us pictures from comic-con you
know we can get into politics but we
have Clinton what is life and it seems
like you're on the road you're always
doing something you were one of the
busiest men in Hollywood it seems except
for now well I'm busy now mr. Tomczyk
I'm actually I'm actually performing my
profession right now which is
communicating that's so right now I'm in
my glory
no that is also true glory um no you
know what I like to stay busy because
idle time is the devil's workshop yeah
there are idle hands are the devil's
workshop
yeah whatever that
not doing nothing is bad for you yeah
exactly especially if your stolen
jacuzzi with nothing but time on your
hands
oh no no then there'd be plenty of
activity I do have a rubber duckie I
could show you later I don't want no but
I don't want to go straight from that
into the rubber de anatomically correct
rubber let's go back let's go back to
Bob no no no I tell you what I I'm doing
I'm doing a couple of personal
appearances I went and did a great
horror convention called horror or how
that was it yeah um and it's really it
sounds it's like a family
it really is it's it's the people are
goofy and and and they're you know it's
their horror fans and there's a few of
them by Sunday they are pretty spun
around the floor of the convention um
but I would imagine you know generally
speaking what I have noticed is over the
years the genres especially the horror
genre it's gotten younger yeah
I mean wait wait hold on say got that
backwards it was younger before okay
there's a lot more middle-aged people
attending horror conventions now than
there was 15 20 years it's not that odd
it just sounds like an aging process at
that point well yeah and you know what
they're the ones with the disposable
dollars and you know yeah another thing
to another thing I did not overcharge
know anybody there because you know I
looked at the people and I saw and you
know these are not the Star Trek people
that have flown from Europe to go to the
50th anniversary convention right these
are these are people with a few bucks in
their pocket and and my job is not to
scrape the last $20 bill out of their
head yeah you know who's notorious for
that is Lou Ferrigno so I don't know if
he's a friend but he I mean he's been
known like you ask him for an autograph
first time it's got to be the right
print and he charges a pretty
competitive yeah yeah
yeah well you know some people figure
it's show business yeah and I just feel
like there ought to be a $10 pile yes
and also that means well a $10 pile it's
like the cheapest available photograph
you can sell somebody it policy is at
least my policy is you need to buy
something for me to take a picture with
you right you
what the what in truth the real science
fiction convention or though or hound
thing or comic-con it's an opportunity
for people to have contact yeah exactly
that's something we appreciate well just
make sure you obviously put on some
drawers when you do that let me ask you
though I wear long pants yeah and I
don't go commando that's learned that's
a bad you can go commando you just can't
tell someone because then it becomes
sexual assault and you know you're in
Bill O'Reilly territory let me ask you
this you're not that far obviously in
Los Angeles but California Berkeley free
speech week I don't know if you've been
following this the yeah I follow
Berkeley imminently I mean the free her
de bout this right free Ben Shapiro was
their free speech week and Coulter and
Milo are going there all these protests
you know you've been raised in
California your whole life and I
maintain that actually this idea that
there was a free speech movement from
the left it was never really that active
was more of a prodrug anti-war movement
seeing these california it's just it's
it's a totalitarian state where people
don't want anything that they disagree
with yeah you know and the problem is
this is not the first time I've seen
liberal minded people co-opted a pretty
solid idea right and run with it and
with the help of the press
all of a sudden wait wait wait fascism
was never a left thing it was always a
right thing yeah help the press can read
the the press can create a new narrative
and all of a sudden the left will be the
ones that are leading the little people
without a voice yeah exactly she's so
full of malarkey it's where they've lost
that don't know that's why they've lost
a blue-collar worker they've lost
everyone except for the extremists you
know on campus and in the entertainment
industry like when you watch the Emmys
it was just one big take a steaming crop
on conservatives fest what's that like
for you I mean obviously working in the
industry and having had to attend so
many awards shows it's gotten so bad
lately it hasn't been funny in years now
yes
you know I'm first of all I don't attend
that many
shows you know an award show is just a
commercial for the business and I feel
like that that you know the business is
taking care of me and paid me and I've
done real well but you know why I don't
need to do commercials for them no ten
dollar pile for the Emmys oh no no no no
it Ami's that's a 20 that's that's
everything gets doubled
that's like Vegas baby yes you're going
for more than scale I just you know back
to the back to the fans you know that
connection where you can shake their
hand and ask their name and BS with them
for a couple of minutes and and and
maybe make a joke about the spelling of
their name or something and then stand
up and do a picture together you know
that means something to them yeah and
the photograph might end up disappearing
almost like my camera disappeared a few
minutes ago it did ah but but the memory
the exchange will remain in them in
their minds and I think that's what's
important I think they have one story I
may have told this I was in Little Rock
Arkansas in 1984 going to a minor-league
baseball game and they announced that I
was in the stands it was the Arkansas
travelers I was down there working on a
movie called end of the line
mm-hm and they announced me and there
was a cheer smattering of applause and
then slowly but surely people started
coming over and having me sign stuff and
I sign like the bottom of the hotdog box
and I signed circuit inside of a bag of
peanuts you know that had been ripped
open and but people were coming up and
having a good time and I was leaked it's
time to go it was the seventh-inning and
I had a call the next morning I called
the cab I go and I have to stop in the
the old stadium style men's room to take
a leak and I'm there at the trough and
I'm urinating and I look down and and
I'm hitting my signature geez my
signature was on a hotdog box that was
in the urinal and that was a humbling
experience people maybe the guy just
dropped it because you know he had one
hot dog in one hand and then
other you know and no I think he just
kind of said yeah well no I'd be come on
let's face it let's just face reality
first of all if you really wanted to
keep it and he dropped it in the urinal
he would have picked it up yeah it
depends on how determined he is but I
would yeah it looks like someone cut
your attention there which is the
humbling moment it was like you know one
minute everybody was patting me on the
back and the stadium announcer was
saying ladies and gentlemen let's give a
nice little Rock welcome to you know
yeah - I'm looking down and I'm you know
like a cow on a flat rock well don't let
that don't let that get your spirits
down I've had people actually urinate on
me so this has happened at stand-up Club
so it did class yeah wait wait wait you
mean you mean in performance after
performance yeah they were it was more
so as they were collapsing drunk
yeah no they didn't like no they didn't
like me very much I was 19 and there was
nothing I could do I needed new shoes
don't don't end this innocent everyone
here loves you you're not on Twitter you
haven't so you have any way of knowing
how often people are your the most
requested guest we have so not here's
the scene there I say I appreciate that
and I have my little Facebook I am my
little Facebook presence and and you
know it's just personal I enjoy you and
I enjoy the whole team and I enjoy the
fact I can sit here with my cell phone
in my jacuzzi and do an interview with a
very smart person is to me kind of an
interesting proposition well thank you
very much we'll listen we have to get
going cause if and we have an McIlhenny
infilling McAleer and then senator Rick
Santorum so it's a weird match tonight
tell tell senator Santorum they Clint
Howard and old fo air we can say that
now because they've pretty much busted
that same time but but Rick came and
spoke and I like Rick I mean I thought
Rick was wonderful I'm a big believer in
Rick I don't think Rick's presidential
timber but he'll you know I didn't think
the Donald Trump was presidential timber
and look who's sitting in the White
House yeah exactly
none of us you know if Charles
Krauthammer gets it wrong half a time
you naked in a Jacuzzi probably haven't
got a shot and neither do I at this
chair but listen next time we we bring
you back let's get you in studio and
we'll make it a party but pants required
yes
yes and I've got a special snow globe
that I want to show you so I don't have
to do a special unveiling just for you
it's not you so don't know I was gonna
say we'll make sure we have a crack
security quad that's Howard and up next
and McIlhenny feelin McAleer thank you
so much for being with us
[Music]
they think I'm not gay gentleman I miss
that one but we're gonna sing not gay
that mean is dude roll it
coochie what what should get out they
don't go home don't you beer your place
now I ran out I don't just take some of
my key stones I get back you're off my
dial-up won't stream HD bro you know
that demon troll just take mop take my
hotspot use that for a knife by the time
I get hooked up I might as well stay and
watch morning grinders for eight hours
[Music]
[Applause]
so what's cool of us today don't push me
off right
[Music]
and that list of this
[Music]
all right glad to have our next guest I
should say guests we've had the Misses
on before but never the mister and he
left me a very sacred mystery as we
talked about a very mocking voice mail
so you have n McElhinney and fill him
McAleer on the show I hope I got both of
them correct to limit and thank you for
being here and the mockery was deserved
it was well deserved by the way here's
the thing I can understand you now I can
understand you in person to Ireland you
know two or three days in Ireland has
you sorted Steven it has me sorted and
in sore need of Zoloft when I had
conversation with the people in Ireland
it was amazing as to how conservative
they lined up on issues and then they
always said put on he totals from I
think Americans or coffee and stew I'm
like you just you have no idea what you
just said you agreed with me on nine out
of ten issues but then you somehow think
that you're a liberal and it made me so
depressed
yeah welcome to our country welcome to
our country and that's why we're not in
that country but here well we're glad to
have you you're a national treasure so
listen you've done this I know you've
been this play in in Los Angeles before
a lot of controversy and now explain to
the audience you are bringing the
Ferguson play to the heart of theater in
Manhattan right we did that steais
reading in Los Angeles are people eating
the script 9p9 members of the cast
walked out during rehearsals because the
truth the script didn't match what they
thought this real story of Ferguson was
so this is a verbatim play I am only
using grand jury testimony it's only if
you're taken directly from the grand
jury and it's the build-up to the
shooting of Michael Brown from
eyewitnesses many of the minorities and
the truth is stranger than fiction but
it's also not that matches nothing what
the mainstream media said the mainstream
media is the real fiction here so I'm
bringing it to - Manhattan - right to
the heart of Manhattan to the urban
stages theater and it was partially
inspired by the way by the way the way
the audience is at Hamilton and the cast
and Hamilton treated at vice president
Mike pants yeah so is this off-broadway
or is it off off-broadway
or is it off
awful okay are you best you showcases if
they Apollo just have to win if damon
wayans come out and I'm next
oh so what is the reaction because in
Los Angeles you got a lot of flack and
remember when people spoke with some of
these actors or participants they said
well I just can't do it it was too
offensive and they were asked but what
about the fact that it's based on
testimony and they had no answer they
just said it's too inflammatory I
remember thinking inflammatory the point
of perhaps inciting false riots you know
so what's what's the reaction like right
now as you bring this to New York well
it's quiet you know so far nothing so
far it's quiet but you know it's early
days it's early days yet yeah and by the
way isn't theatre supposed to be
inflammatory you know if they weren't so
busy giving themselves rewards for being
award for being brave and courageous
it's actually time for them to be
courageous so that's I think it's again
in flamer Torrey yes the flame like
don't give an award it's like rent is
one of the longest ring we're gonna give
it another award this year it's about
people getting AIDS having gay sex and
truck stop shooting heroin they're on
borrowed time let's move on from this so
it really is it's it's I think you see
that with the Emmys the ratings will I
don't even know what it is with the
Tonys but it is so self-important to me
what really bothers me and I think it's
ties back into the Hamilton issue with a
vice president I was gonna say governor
pence buts vice president Mike Pence is
just the assumption that everyone agrees
with you he's in there and it's the
assumption that will everyone in the
audience thinks it's fine everyone no
one would have a problem with me
berating the vice president of United
States right exactly as you say see what
it was like at the Emmys you know do
they you know I'm feeling I have a big
conversation about this it's incredible
to me that they would be so like they're
they're you know speaking ill of half of
their audience has a whole half of their
audience of all these shows of all these
shows that are on out you know
everywhere half of the audience are
people who think it's a great thing that
Donald Trump is the president United
States right
they just completely ignore that and
it's like just my commercial point of
view it's beyond it's beyond belief
you know how the derangement syndrome
that they're you know they're living in
this kind of really weird
it's like that bubble where they
actually don't know anyone who's voted
for Donald Trump except for they do know
people who don't vote it for Donald
Trump and there's too scared to say it
because he won't be invited to
Thanksgiving or whatever yeah well you
won't be invited to the next Tony's you
know it's funny I think I'll even give
them some ground say okay not even half
but let's say there's twenty percent who
are huge Hillary Clinton fans twenty
percent who are huge Donald Trump fans
and then there's that portion of middle
like okay let's see what happens it's
kinda like Owen Benjamin our friend was
talking about he says you know there's a
small group of people who the left
points to with Charlottesville who go
your people and then there's the
liberals want us to think that all of us
need to be like people but most of
America is like white people you know
there's this guilt complex and they use
this small radical minority of people
who genuinely are racist and try and
apply that to Ferguson and then
obfuscate the truth let me ask you this
because there have been so many since
you've you know started this project to
play of Ferguson I mean just recently
was it in Georgia was it what's the
University of Georgia Tech was at
Georgia Tech on his birthday
Georgia Tech a suicide-by-cop fire if
you watch the video couldn't be more
clear where a man is walking toward a
police officer with a gun out of his
mind out of his mind demanding to be
shot riots after that do you feel as
though you've been somewhat vindicated
of this controversy considering how many
cases have been debunked since the start
of it well I mean Ferguson is the origin
myths for the black lives matter I mean
yeah I mean funny I want I wanted to
kind of show you this guy's like the
technical guys I hope they can see that
this is an article from you from the New
York Times yes from yesterday yes
Ferguson shooting which again you know
this case hasn't been heard yet you know
there'll be a lengthy trial etc but yeah
I'm sorry there has been a lengthy trial
and in a lengthy trial with a proper and
legal system you know the cop was
vindicated and here's here's the story I
mean it's really worth looking at I'm
not gonna lie to you we can't see it
your screen just went dark but you know
well we'll do our best to get it up here
hands up don't you synchronize guesting
you're both that's a screenshot that's
gonna be a gif right there alright
continue
this is a lie and but that'll I have
traveled up the globe millions we were
we were here in more in in LA and by the
way we didn't do this we didn't buy
these tickets ourselves somebody bought
tickets for us to go to see well no in
YouTube you know they don't to YouTube
he's good friend of Senator Santorum
[Laughter]
but he's actually good friends with
senator Rick Santorum was coming up next
he's keys come around a little bit but
he can be a douche yeah and would like
the senator by the way to please give
him some instruction on what actually
happened in Ferguson he did world tour
and during this world tour one of the
pieces the set pieces was there was this
really really long stage and he walked
the length of it hands up don't shoot
hands up don't shoot and we're sitting
there thinking you know it's time for us
to go right now because he was
propagating that line Michael Brown did
not have his hands up saying hands up
don't you did he in his hands in the
cookie jar at the gas station his hands
used to assault the owner of the
convenience store his hands were used to
assault the police officer try and grab
has done and his hands were used to run
towards the police officer to try and
kill him there wasn't but his hands were
never there and what is the main thing
about the play about the Ferguson play
we should you know which we said is
verbatim it's all the words of actual
witnesses at the trial and one of the
most powerful moments I know Steven if
you're anywhere near New York any of the
people listening now near New York
please come give them a data in time
right now with the exact same time from
October 19th to November 5th sixteen
performances Manhattan go to Ferguson
the play www from the play calm and if
you can't go but you believe in what
we're trying to achieve here give us a
dollar
give us a thousand dollars somebody did
this morning god bless them god save
them we're crowdfunding to make this
thing happen the Manhattan theatrical
establishment they've already said to
Mike pants and all of us know
conservatives welcome here so I'm saying
and here I'm going there and went into
the heart of your city and we're telling
the truth I'm a just by the way you
might be kind of surprising for some of
the people who go to the theater in New
York City shocking it could be
inflammatory yeah
Oh monitoring Ferguson to plate I'll
cover cried fontina because the
establishment won't won't won't fund us
they'd rather fund as you say rant where
oh my god if you live a terrible
lifestyle you make it is yeah I know I
know I'm we had a debate about that we
did a week I gave my dog aids in a
sketch took her section the way out now
because it were we did we do a history
lesson on the the AIDS epidemic and how
it was a hoax from the media and this is
again people don't understand that this
idea and seeming with Ferguson we've
talked about this so much in the show
this idea of focusing on victim culture
and let's say it creates actual victims
so when you lie about aids when you say
anyone can get aids through any sexual
practice you're just as at risk if
you're a non intravenous heterosexual
you know drug user if you're none of
those things what happens is aids gets
all of this funding Bono played a huge
role in that in the kid with type 1
diabetes gets a fraction of it because I
don't have a celebrity campaign same
thing with Ferguson what people don't
understand is these kids here this it
gives them license to go out and treat
cops horribly to behave terribly and
then they put themselves in precarious
you create actual victims and it's not
that no I know it's not that you don't
care it's that you care about the real
potential victims absolutely so we
really hope that people come and see the
play and if they can't come and see the
play we really hope that they'll donate
to make this happen you know this is
exactly what our aside if you like this
is what the conservatives don't do we
don't I mean I don't know when was the
last time there was a conservative play
where the conservative point of view
telling the truth in bra on Broadway you
know it just doesn't happen and I think
the response we've had already about 25
percent of the monies are raised already
has kind of proved to us the people all
over the place you know we've got people
like literally all over the place I mean
one of the donors donated he's worried
he's American but he's living in
Indonesia you know we got those kind of
people are you know really believes it
strongly and what we're trying to do and
we're very proud and the play is
unbelievable by the way Steven it is
unbelievable just east reading was
incredible and culture was in the front
row beside me
and Ann Coulter basically said her
biggest problem was that the play didn't
have a longer run and Dennis Prager saw
it and said it was an instant you know
unbelievable night of theater he said it
was life-changing yeah
changed his life yeah you know so
honestly it so it's a
nice tobert 19th - November 5th if you
can't come to New York for that it's
Ferguson the play.com and if you come
I'll be there there are prints to be
hand there's chap to be Habs absolutely
listen maybe we can see if we can make
it work and let's see if especially if
there are any protests are showing
upsets Ferguson the play.com people can
go there donate help support it and I'm
interested to see what comes of this and
this is this is like the Irish male
female diamond and silk meet Abbot and
Costello is the limit and thank you so
much we'll have you back soon as the
play we'll see what unfolds and my task
[Music]
under now for technical difficulties
with Clint Howard sponsored by mug club
hang on give me a second I've got this
tripod there we go
I'm almost giving you an angle here hang
on I'm just this would be an $800 grip
gap if I frigging um this is teetering
on the edge of apple disaster here when
you go back and look at clips of Don
Knotts doing comedy oh yeah there's no
there was nobody better ever as broad as
as broad as Don was this has been
technical difficulties with Clint Howard
sponsored by bug Club
oh we're still trying to get Clint
Howard on so listen really glad that
you're here with us and how alive it a
few weeks it's been a while been three
weeks and that's because the only live
reads were when we were doing hurricane
relief recovery yeah I know cuz there
been so many since then watch I'm in the
comments section what are you doing for
Puerto Rico nothing they're on their own
we did we did a lot for Harvey and we're
going to tally up those numbers and get
them for you next week so that was our
spot how many food-kits and just a
dollar amount
how many dollars went to the Houston
Food Bank cuz by the way I know all
these other hurricanes have happened
there in the news but it's it's still
going on so thank you so much and the
relief is going to be I think pretty
significant for them but a lot of credit
come slash mug club for people who are
watching this on Thursday we do this we
do this deal every single day we do it
every day but Howard's not fair fair
really on the show and it's 69 if you're
69 dollars annually if you're student
veteran military it's a wonderful hand -
monkey get that any also get access to
not only us but mark levin michelle
malkin i gosh i don't know they're there
i don't know if they're new now i don't
know if they've been announced the new
names i'm not entirely sure but they're
actually there's one that's not either
this week or next week and then they're
going to be a couple more and by the way
if you want to also more Owen Benjamin
you can tweet him and let him know at
Owen Benjamin people really liked him
coming love her and sketches but you
know people because all the D
monetization on YouTube is happening and
ironically this is what allows us to
keep the content on YouTube so you see
lies people hit the tip jar hit patreon
keep keep this content free well we're
going to do free content no matter what
but we're only able to do it if more
people join the club and and we didn't
want to do it with just you know
standing there with a cup that's the
time are you we wanted actually provide
some value added and we're bringing on
more people you keep twelve people fully
entirely employed made in America
because you know we don't hire anyone
who speak Spanish latte with greater
calm slash mug club and some pretty cool
things are coming down the pike for
members so get the mug while you can it
might just go away it might go away
[Music]
all right glad our next guest always a
great instrument this is why the book or
producers say they're never they're not
coming back not coming back you know you
can follow them on twitter at rick
santorum hip senator the united states
former senator a guy right now he's
obviously he's all over the television
and the interwebs senator santorum
thanks for being with us sir thank you
first time actually on the show that's
true on the show yeah we nurture the
promise just at his daughter's wedding
in ireland you know as I was telling was
wonderful was in a castle and after that
nothing I've done for my wife is good
enough we literally walk in to an old
Irish castle and they're going ah okay
you're obviously making sort of making
the rounds for people who don't know we
have this bill now this bill it looks
like it might get passed you know
Republican health care bill Graham
Cassidy
let's put Jimmy Kimmel's comments aside
for a second gave us kind of just the
the summary of it for people have no
idea how is it different from the other
bills that never went through yeah
it's similar in some respects and
differed in a major respect it's similar
in that both bills Block Grant Medicaid
so it takes a federal entitlement
Medicaid and it puts it on an a what's
gone what I just it's actually called a
per capita cap
what's that mean it means that they're
gonna get so much money per person under
under Medicaid and and so it's not an
open-ended entitlement any more in other
words it's we're gonna give so much per
person
we're not just gonna reimburse whatever
whatever the state spends so right
that's some limitation on the growth of
Medicaid frankly it's not a whole lot
because we grow the growth of the cap if
you will every year by the rate roughly
of medical inflation a little higher in
the early years at medical inflation in
the later years so what does that mean
that people who are complaining about
that and this was again in the other
bill so it's the same as an hour bill
yeah the people are complaining
they're saying that was a big cut to
Medicaid but think about this Steven
we're growing the Medicaid pot because
you know the per capita allocation right
person is gonna grow at medical
inflation that's the aggregate inflation
in medicine
sure and so what we're saying is
Medicaid is now gonna have to grow at
that level that all medicine is growing
that right well it's very comfortable I
would say for a lot of people cuz we
talked about this in the show quite a
bit in ways to the idea of a school
voucher program where instead of just
giving it into an endless supply of a
public school it isn't working you
attach it to the student and in that
case more students would go to public
schools and private schools so there
would be a larger pool so so the bottom
line is this is really the key though
the growth rate is what people are
complained about they're saying that's
an unrealistic growth rate but think
about this Bernie Sanders and Kamala
Harris and all these people went out
Cory Booker went out last week and said
we need Medicare for everybody because
it's a more efficient it's a better
system it's better quality and it's and
it's lower cost but they're complaining
that Medicaid with a cap at medical
inflation is coming is it is it's gonna
fail yeah so think about it
what's medical inflation well that's the
aggregate amount of everybody on medical
care and if Medicaid is gonna fail
because it is not can't keep up with the
average which means they're higher costs
right exactly well there's a lot of
people don't realize fewer and fewer
doctors are taking it as well it's
become a real problem and when we talk
about the people who are left in the
cold because the Affordable Care Act
there are tens of millions of Americans
who can no longer afford their plans
there are millions who their plans that
included Medicaid aren't taken you know
my in-laws they've had a real problem
with it so I think the issue you're
running into cuz you're trying to make
sense of the hypocrisy from Bernie
Sanders none of that is the case it's
just that it's a human right that's
that's the endgame so they don't want to
work with you on that no they don't but
that to me that's a very reasonable way
of approaching the Medicaid program we
keep that that was in the original bill
here's the big difference the big
difference is we take that's traditional
Medicaid that's Medicaid before Barack
Obama expanded Medicaid
so what we do in our bill is we take the
Medicaid expansion and eliminate it we
take the tax credits that are given to
people on Obamacare exchanges and
eliminate it we take the cost-sharing
reduction payments that are given to
insurance companies to lower the cost of
deductibles and we eliminate we take the
Medicaid and the the exchanges no longer
we take the the all of the regulations
we allow a lot of waivers in those
regulations yeah so all of that is all
of that is changed and sorry about that
a bottomless yeah if the federal
government runs your electric over there
yeah give it back to the states okay so
all of those things are repealed and
what's that replacement well oh by the
way the individual mandate is repeal and
the employer mandate is repealed okay so
all of those things basically Obamacare
is repealed right what we then do is
take all the tax money that's left
because the Obama increased taxes and we
take that money and we divide it up to
the states equally over time not every
regionally but we phase it in but by the
end of the of the seven years of this
Block Grant every state will get the
same amount per capita for the poor
people they have in their state so they
can provide a innovative state specific
quality driven system of health
insurance and help providing for each
state in America so we get the money out
of Washington yeah get it equally
divided to the states allow them to
innovate allow them to create high-risk
pools or House savings accounts or if
they want to put you know I a llama care
in recreate Obamacare I'm in California
right now they want to recreate
Obamacare in California they can
recreate Obamacare here they want to put
at the individual mandate they can put
back the individual mandate but every
state is gonna have the ability to
develop their own system and it'll be
driven by two things number one there's
a there's a there's a limit we put a cap
on how much money we're gonna spend so
every unlike Obamacare which is
open-ended entitlement if there's a
limit on how much money we're gonna
we're gonna give the states and they
have to
within that budget that's gonna drive
cost containment which which is the best
way to get cost containment is improving
quality so we think will have a lower
cost more efficient quality driven
system in all the different states
around the console EFT opposes it we
know why Jimmy Kimmel wants to you know
kick your ass effectively that's going
on now apparently he's taking out the
brass knuckles for Brian Kilmeade toss
his baby at you yeah he's literally
thrown what children do we have that we
can throw so we know where the left is
against it but I've heard you also say
hey listen this is why the right needs
to support it so there's been some
apprehension from more traditional
conservatives I think I know the reason
but I'd like to hear kind of what it is
they've expressed to you and why they do
need to get behind it at this point
well in Rand Paul's would have been
leading that charge saying that we leave
in 85 to 90% of the taxes that Obama
loudly to fund Obamacare and we leave
the spending in place and the answer to
that is we do we do cut although a
quarter of a trillion dollars in taxes
we do reduce spending by 400 billion
dollars we do get the money out to the
states and you know we end to in federal
entitlements so you know it's not bad
baby stop sign it's as far as I'm
concerned like but it's I I hearken back
you know this is before you were born I
what I twenty years ago when I was thank
you you're far too kind
all right I'll forgive you for the the
Irish castle opulence continue so 20
years ago 21 years ago to be exact I we
I was the author of a bill that passed
the on state Senate signed by President
Clinton called welfare reform and there
were those there was a guy by the name a
lock fair clock who was a senator from
North Carolina who voted against he was
the only Republican that voted against
this bill they got every other
Republican to vote for it 51 of them to
go for it because it didn't cut enough
taxes and it didn't cut enough spending
and and the reason is because we spend a
lot of money waiting the reason we spend
a lot of money and welfare was that's
how we got bipartisan support we put
enough money in a blocker into the state
to reform the welfare system but here's
what we did we gave the states that the
governors
flexibility to reform the program and
guess what happened within three years
the welfare rules were cut in half
within three years poverty hit some of
the lowest rates in fact then the most
hard hard hit pop impoverished you know
subcategories had the best growth in in
income we had we've got more people
employed who were lower income
particularly single never married
mother's highest rates of employment
ever recorded yeah all because we gave
the governance of flexibility and the
resources table to get people off
welfare into work into productive lives
well I understand yet finding a middle
ground compromise so that we can get
something is better than nothing but I
enjoy both agree it just takes the wrong
guy down the line unless something is
completely dragon is cut off if the head
where you know you have another
President Obama and people are concerned
that oh now it's all back in play as it
often happens with government look
here's here are the options it was not
coincidental that the day that Lindsey
Graham and Bill Cassie and Dean Heller
and Ron Johnson I introduced they
introduced I hung around we're at a
press conference introducing that this
this bill later on that day Bernie
Sanders introduced his Medicare for all
yeah and and just think about the optics
of this well the legal term is crazy
uncle proposed a bill again that's how
we that's how it's referred to let's use
the proper vernacular but I'm making for
all is a little concerning these
remember yeah so the interesting about
those two press conferences they both
had the same underlying point Obamacare
doesn't work because if Obamacare worked
for any women introducing a
fundamentally different way of dealing
with health care so now the left or the
right agree Obamacare has failed and now
the American public has their choice
they can do a plan that says 50
different health care health care
systems developed at people closest and
at the states and people closest to the
people to make more localized solutions
or one-size-fits-all government-run
health care by the Democrats that's your
choice and that's the vote coming up
next week Gerald Heather that has a
question here yes senator Santorum I
think I feel like this is kind of like
college football where I support a team
that gets beat
the last minute I just can't do it
anymore as a Republican as somebody
who's had his insurance co crazy I don't
know that there's just two choices in
our minds right now there there are two
choices but there's this third option of
like no you got to come up with
something a little bit better how do you
get over the hurdle of communicating
that this is a good path to go because
I'm with you I'm all for the states
having the right to control this but it
doesn't seem like everybody's jumping on
the bandwagon on both sides so that like
Stephen said it doesn't just go back the
next time we get somebody from another
party coming in how do you know well
here's this is the cool thing about
sending the money out to the states
once the states have these resources and
develop their own plan of how to deal
with insurance markets and the
pre-exists all these things that we're
going to give them the flexibility to
deal with
they're never gonna give this money back
you know that's a very good boy yeah so
this puts a stake through the heart of
single-payer it's one of the biggest
selling points of this is not a not a
single Democratic governor if they've
helped develop this system in their
state it's going to say oh no no we'll
end this and let the Garf with federal
government take this from us no way not
gonna happen
yeah it really does seem like it's a
battle of optics at this point everyone
agrees and that was one thing when when
senators Antone was running it was down
to him and Mitt Romney I remember being
on Fox News I said listen this is at the
time when at this point Affordable Care
Act is at an all-time it's never gonna
be less popular than right now but it
was there were so many problems with it
I said what does what does Mitt Romney
gonna do and I like Governor Romney but
he went up in that second debate and he
just sidestepped in ah this is the time
to do it so I Pro the lights just went
out
suckee coming again he's in Utah right
click all right before we go we just had
by the way Clint Howard says hi he was
he was on the show right before he was
in a hot tub
III presumably nude so I don't know what
that says we said I really like my
senators and I met him at fo away and I
don't know if you remember him but it's
a tough mug to frame I'm very
uncomfortable with this okay well that's
where can people read more about this
bill for people who don't know because
it's tough to kind of you know wade
through all of them
with this especially there are two good
op-eds in the Wall Street Journal today
that I would recommend to you that I
think did a very good job
obviously you know you can go to both
center Cassey and center Graham's
website that has all the details that
you never want to have a have on the
bill a lot of the myths there's a posted
something up just I think yesterday or
today on all the misinformation like you
know we're not covering people with
pre-existing conditions that Jimmy
Kimmel test that's garbage
you know what we do is we tell the
states you have to cover pre-existing
conditions but we're gonna give you
flexibility on how you do it so there
can be innovative solutions to provide
better and more affordable care for for
those with friezes condition this is
this is the kind of stuff
unless see for Jimmy Kimmel and for
people with simple minds that they may
be the same person that if you don't say
the federal government makes you do it
then
then then it doesn't count yeah well you
know what there are there are many ways
to deal with with providing good quality
accessible and affordable health care
and we want to we want to make sure that
that happens and make sure everybody
gets the best quality care at the best
price I want federal I want the federal
government to take over late-night and
then wash Bernie Sanders we'll have a
show has been already pretty much a
fresh thinking lights all the same
aerosol right that is senator Rick
Santorum you can follow him at Rick
Santorum I think senator Santorum it's
too long for the Twitter handle but yeah
it's too long people won't remember
thank you so much senator for taking the
time and help listen people let us know
in the comments section what you think
about this bill where you're lining up
we always want to have our finger to the
pulse and see where they are it seems as
though there's there's a split so
hopefully something gets done say hey
take a slice when you can get it done
all over it for 40 years they take a
little bit at a time and all of a sudden
you realize what happened you realize
the pie is a rhubarb pie win big or go
home don't win big go home it take the
first down move the ball down the field
there you go
fair analogy senator Rick Santorum thank
you so much for taking the time sir
there's music that means we have to come
[Music]
greetings Otto of car of yours
hopper here you may have noticed my new
phrase Haggadah monado is quite a shop
calm where you can get your shirt there
socialism is for figs on the firearm
shirt and does some really cool clothes
afterward a woman
[Music]
[Music]
the riptides almost got me I was blocked
out there who's got me on the Riptide do
you ever wonder what people think you
listen to the audio only version of this
sometimes I wonder like sometimes people
on the ropes we appreciate you listening
audio only gentle clip Thank You senator
Rick Santorum a little different we
don't often have hope but you know he's
easy he's making around he's a good guy
do you think he explained it in a way
that is actually pretty yeah simple
variable Thank You Clint Howard next
time wear pants and thank you to film
and we very much appreciate it and at
the busy week next week there will be no
show on Wednesday you'll find out why on
Thursday we can't divulge that
information yet but should be good I
also think I'm doing a segment over
there was stefan molyneux on his show we
could doing oh yeah we're doing a mock
debate on abortion so yeah we didn't
mock debate before and people for some
reason still think that I was Pro better
States who's gonna take which stands now
you want me to take the pro-life stance
cuz the last time I took these sort of
just but your opposite you'll argue me I
decide to take the contrarian stance
left that's a better word for where yeah
all right and give me the rope you're
gonna burn yourself that's why we give
you the words you mealy-mouthed son of a
[ __ ] so I am okay so this is this is
the last segment and and I turn in a
cage here and I said what do you have he
said nothing because I don't have any
thoughts don't this just empty up there
I can't figure out like what I did I did
apologize to Jared this week you know
apologizing we cannot kid you it on air
because we we've had some issues and and
he was wrong on some of them but then I
was wrong because I told him to stop
acting like a little [ __ ] you did I
actually said that and afterwards right
I even no matter even about how wrong he
was before that okay and listen Paula
geez no ifs ands or buts and in moved on
it I've had to do that this week a
little bit we've been kind of it I don't
say a pressure-cooker you'll see again
next Thursday what we don't have a video
what we don't have a show next Wednesday
and it's because of a super video and
and one that actually safety concerns
sure and there are a lot of things
happening with the studio there are a
lot of things happening with mug club
and see our TV and new shows coming on
and so there's been a lot sometimes just
have those weeks where there's just too
many plates spinning and that's what
Jordan Peterson said with me that
defensive reactive aggression also
you're three percent politeness three
percent politeness that is a portion of
it but um
you know what the truth is yeah there
are things that I'm working on I know
that there are things that na kijiye is
is working on another things that sound
good I know there are things that
everybody is working on and this
conversation with my wife about it
because I've learned to apologize I've
done it a lot throughout my life and you
know and I hope people in my life
understand and I think most people do
that you know you make mistakes it it
doesn't really come from malice that's a
big thing and here's how I think that
most people around tend to know that if
you just look at jarrod and Gerald the
people who work in this in this office
and I'm gonna tie this around to well
Jimmy Kimmel you look at Vox you look at
how it just you know authentic they are
with well we support free speech but
someone's saying that in writing that on
voxcom right writing yes I support free
speech and then the whole article is not
supporting free speech when I see that I
don't just think hey this person is a
liar I think hey this person is a fraud
in what's crazy is you know Vox has I
don't know how many hundreds of
employees they're comfortable putting
that out there with headlines in a
support free speech and knowing they
don't because they must be surrounded by
people who don't know or don't care that
they're a fraud you think the people in
the opposite Vox don't know they go yeah
Clarke studies Pro free speech in that
headline they all know that he's not but
they're surrounded by people who don't
care there's run by people who have no
standard as to integrity and I think
that's one thing we have in our office
we talk about a lot we we send out memos
we say hey listen everyone needs to have
a good attitude you need to look out for
the guy next to you if someone comes
down on someone you know there's a
system of obviously I wouldn't use the
word boss but there are people or
different hierarchies if someone comes
down on someone it's usually
hey listen the guy next to you had to
make up for that work it doesn't come
from hating somebody and so even if I
know that I can be Curt these are things
that I need to work and I'm just an open
book I said Jared stop being acting like
a little [ __ ] I was wrong and he was
but I shouldn't have said it
how many people get an apology from
their boss live on air you're welcome
you and your cheekbones sign over my
creator this week bones and you'll
understand why next I there's no there's
no show Wednesday this is this is then I
can explain the discussions as to what
when
it'll make a lot more sense because I
can I can see how there was some
pressure there and possible so people
can be flawed and I am deeply flawed I
think everyone does but if for me to not
be a good man or for me to not try and
be a good man would make me a fraud and
it would be an office that I could not
walk into tomorrow let alone day in and
day out if I were to come out here and
tell you hey I you know I I believe that
that conservatives should do a better
job for example of paying their
employees at least a fair wage because
I've talked about that was conservative
nonprofits I've talked about working
with other conservative organizations
who I've talked about many entities who
offered to hire me for no money asked me
to move across the country but you've
heard me talk about on the show if I
were to say that on this show and talk
about how disgusting it were and
everyone in this office knew that I was
paying them like I'd be a fraud if I
were to come out here and say you know
what hey family really matters and you
know I think that before federal
government for state government you tell
me the central building block is the
family and everyone in this office knew
that I treated my family like crap that
I hated my wife that I didn't have a
good relationship on their parents guess
what they know really quickly that I'm a
fraud I'd be exposed really quickly and
I'm not just saying this because it's
not to be self-aggrandizing or even if
any other people on this teams because
on this team because they're there
they're the heroes the unsung heroes in
this story they're the ones who are
going to keep someone accountable but it
is a really good place to be I was this
if you can set up your life you know you
look at Vox you look it up and in post
you look at Slate you look at what once
was Gawker these are entire businesses
set up jimmy kimmel set up around
avoiding the truth they said don't talk
religion in politics why because these
people don't practice what they preach
they don't believe these things and so
they set up a system that allows for
fraud they set up a system of hierarchy
they set up an office place that allows
them to lie to people on their shows it
allows them to lie in their columns I
support free speech and a good example
Tom Hanks remember scene I'm an MSNBC
said yes world war two the United States
only entered because of racism and fear
and we're sitting there going you don't
have anyone in your life who will say
that's [ __ ] sir that's one of the
stupidest things that are earned because
they set up a life
they can be a fraud and no one calls my
if you can set up your life able to this
we've done it with this office we've
done it with this with this program
we've done it with water with better
calm Courtney's not shy to let you know
if she's angry about something if you
can do that with your life and set it up
so that you can't be a fraud because
everyone around you everyone around you
knows it and they'll call you out on it
that's a really good place to be
especially if not being a good person if
not being a good man it's what makes you
fraudulent you want to know how you get
better you want to know how you increase
whatever your capacity for whatever it
is whether it's intellectually
emotionally spiritually you surround
yourself with people who will call you
on your crap people who will tell you if
you're not a good man and I know a lot
of people who don't have had people
recently friend always talked with going
yeah you know my friends just don't
think about these issues they just don't
really care about it I'm going okay so
let's say you screw up let's say you
don't really treat your wife really well
let's say for let's say you know you're
violating your own conscience who of
your friends is going to tell you who's
gonna you know they don't know they
don't like to talk about that they just
you know they just want to have a good
time yeah don't talk religion in
politics because it sifts through the
frauds really quickly and I realized
that this week when I had to sit down
and I'm the boss technically but even my
wife I'm like hey you know what you have
to apologize for that
if I didn't have that and if I didn't
have that every single day every
checkmark doesn't mean I'm it doesn't
mean I'm perfect I mean I don't have a
long way to go
I would develop into the biggest fraud
that you could possibly imagine because
when people aren't calling you on and
all they're doing is complimenting you
all they're doing is praising you and it
becomes one big ego stroke you wonder
how does Jimmy Kimmel get so out of
touch man you wonder how do the Emmys
have no self-awareness whatsoever that
not every single person in the country
could possibly some could possibly
disagree how does look we're talking
with an and flim how does this leave
these actors and Hamilton think that
it's okay to berate the vice president
of United States how would it know where
that half that audience might disagree
because they have been allowed to be
frauds their entire life and that
happens when you make the first
decisions who you surround yourself with
how you act and how you act when those
people react being a fraud if you're not
a good person
that's a really good place to be it
means you've got a solid foundation
I'm grateful for it see you next week
with night Clinton
[Music]